[Musica]
per prima cosa vorrei che ciascuno di
voi tirasse fuori il portafoglio e
prendesse una banconota o una moneta
fidatevi vi servirà perché oggi voglio
parlarvi della mia visione del futuro
del denaro per capire il futuro però
dobbiamo comprendere il passato
iniziando con la storia di questa antica
civiltà gli abitanti di yap una piccola
isola del pacifico hanno conservato fino
ai giorni nostri
un'antica cultura in mezzo secolo di
cambiamenti la loro moneta è davvero
interessante usano dischi di calcare
chiamate pietre rai è spesso più alte di
un uomo e per e pensate pesanti fino a
quattro tonnellate e per quanto possa
sembrare assurdo capire come funzionano
offre una finestra sul futuro del denaro
una delle cose interessanti di questa
storia è che le pietre di yap venivano
estratte su un'isola vicina e quindi
spostate via mare se sopraggiungeva una
tempesta i marinai spesso si trovavano
costretti a gettarle della zattera pur
di salvarsi un denaro così pesante e
difficile da sollevare capite aveva dei
problemi di trasporto
perciò non si scambiava se ne chiedeva
la proprietà una pietra fuori da casa
tua
poteva diventare quella del tuo vicino
semplicemente dichiarandolo in pubblico
la tradizione orale quindi era così
forte che secondo alcuni dei primi
esploratori anche il denaro gettato in
mare
rimaneva parte del sistema economico
dell'isola che differenza fa se la
pietra è fuori da casa mia
oppure sul fondo del pacifico non c'è
alcuna differenza
questa tradizione è ancora oggi noso la
persona a cui appartiene il denaro è la
stessa che tutti ricordano come il
legittimo proprietario
sull'isola di yap quindi la tradizione
orale è una sorta di registro contabile
che tutti gli abitanti condividono la
moneta
una storia condivisa su chi possiede
cosa è una storia in cui tutti crediamo
e questo significa che la moneta è
sempre stata solo questione di fiducia
l'antico sistema di yap gli euro nella
vostra banca
e anche le banconote che state tenendo
in mano in questo momento funzionano
perché tutti noi crediamo che abbiano
valore in fondo pensi davvero ci sia
differenza tra le pietre di yap è un
pezzo di carta che tiene in mano è solo
un pezzo di carta ma se vieni da me per
comprare un panino lo accetto perché
entrambi crediamo che abbia valore e
l'impero sistema di scambio lo crede
insieme a noi
eppure c'è una grande differenza che
potrebbe rendere il denaro di yap un
modello per il futuro
gli isolani di yap ricordavano chi
possedeva alle pietre senza bisogno di
un intermediario come una banca o come
un governo quando si vive in un piccolo
villaggio tutti conoscono la storia non
c'è bisogno che qualcuno la ricorda a
tutti
da dove viene la pietra quante volte è
stata scambiata più persone lo sanno e
piu il sistema è sicuro tutti voi potete
affermare che la banconota che tengo in
mano in questo momento sia mia se adesso
uno di voi provasse a dire che in realtà
è sua
saremo 100 contro 1 la sua bugia non
riuscirebbe a cambiare la verità cioè la
storia che tutti noi stiamo condividendo
et voilà ecco il grande segreto per il
futuro del denaro
in sostanza questa idea di conoscenza
condivisa e anche alla base delle più
recenti forme di denaro digitale come
bitcoin in un certo senso bitcoin non è
nient'altro che un ritorno a questo
precedente concetto di registrazione
comune di memoria comune bitcoin è
apparso poco dopo una forte crisi che ha
scosso la fiducia delle persone del
mondo nei confronti degli intermediari
finanziari
ecco perché nel 2009 un programmatore o
un gruppo anonimo volevano costruire
quello che voleva essere e vuole essere
un sistema monetario alternativo sono
cene riusciti a fare una cosa
apparentemente impossibile trovare un
modo per inviare denaro tra me e te
tra me e no e poi senza più un
intermediario come una banca o un
governo contro l'asse l'operazione
stavano cercando di togliere dall
equazione economica il protagonista
della crisi finanziaria del 2008
vi faccio un esempio per capire
esattamente come funziona bitcoin è la
totale imparzialità della sua tecnologia
se adesso scendesse da questo palco e
regalassi la mia banconota a te la
transazione sarebbe immediata sarebbe
diretta ma questo punto la domanda è
come potete essere sicuri voi e che io
non lo stia fregando come sapete ad
esempio che la banconota non è falsa
se non c'è una banca da fare da garante
la risposta è semplice 700 testimoni 700
paia d'occhi che possono controllare la
banconota venire a vederla e toccarla
ed effettivamente siete tutti i
testimoni che la moneta la banconota
stia passando dalle mie mani alle sue a
quelle di uno di voi
chi meglio di voi può essere il garante
anche se non ve ne siete accorti
abbiamo appena scritto la prima riga
della nostra storia comune
proprio come se fossimo sull'isola di
yap bitcoin è una rivoluzione perché
rende reale proprio questo fa in modo
che la comunità torni a essere custode
della sua storia che la comunità
controlli ogni scambio di denaro e non
lasci più spazio a menzogna e
tendenziosa
tutti noi abbiamo visto lo scambio tutti
noi lo ricordiamo chi meglio di voi
quindi può essere il garante
la vera domanda ora è questa ma bitcoin
come fa a renderlo reale in fondo è una
moneta digitale
qual è il nostro ruolo per scoprirlo
dobbiamo guardare oltre bitcoin cercando
di capire la sua tecnologia bitcoin
esiste grazie alla block chain catena di
blocchi possiamo immaginare la block
chain come una versione globale digitale
e automatizzata della tradizione orale
che tracciava la proprietà delle pietre
gli up
perciò se la tradizione orale e la
nostra bluff cena le pietre di yap sono
i nostri bitcoin ciò che la tecnologia
block china sfrutta per costruire alla
memoria condivisa non sono le persone ma
dispositivi come computer altamente
sofisticati che prestano la loro potenza
di calcolo per elaborare e verificare e
poi archiviare ogni transazione e se ci
riescono
vengono ricompensati in bitcoin per il
loro lavoro
incredibile vero ecco dove sta la cosa
straordinaria
la block chain mi consente di mandare
denaro quando voglio in pochi istanti e
senza un intermediario che controlli la
correttezza dell'operazione perché il
suo posto lo possono fare tutti i
dispositivi connessi a bruxelles
ciò significa togliere il potere da un
unico punto centrale e ridistribuirlo
nella comunità che utilizza la blog
chain la block chain rimuove le
istituzioni dal flusso del denaro allo
stesso tempo restituisce la proprietà
del denaro alle persone che appunto
possiedono un pezzo di quella blu china
che si chiama bitcoin comprende bitcoin
ai la proprietà di quel pezzo di
tecnologia che nessuno ti può togliere
bloccare o congelare chi può proibire
bitcoin nessuno
coi nella blog chain funzionano come
internet non sono di nessuno e nessuno
può bloccarle può spegnerle sono globali
ecco perché così potente la loro forza
rivoluzionaria internet ha reso la
fruizione delle informazioni libera
fluida globale e condivisa
ora è tempo che questo accada per il
denaro ma quindi che cos'è davvero il
dava il denaro cos'è davvero il denaro
a cosa serve il denaro e fiducia il
denaro è un mezzo una sorta di
ambasciatore neutrale e come tale fa sì
che due persone che non si conoscono
possano cooperare tra loro tramite
scambi di valore
la questione della fiducia è la vera
chiave di lettura attraverso la quale
vorrei invitarvi a leggere il denaro se
da una parte il denaro è stato il primo
e più grande conquistatore della storia
per il quale si sono condotte le
peggiori guerra e sono avvenute le crisi
economiche di più ampia portata ha
permesso milioni e miliardi di persone
di cooperare tra loro tramite scambi
questo ci riporta le nostre promesse
iniziali nelle pietre rai né le
banconote che avete in mano in questo
momento hanno un valore intrinseco
effettivamente non hanno nulla di
speciale
le pietre di yap le pietre rai e non
sono fatte di materiale prezioso e le
banconote che tenete in mano come tutti
dovreste sapere non hanno più come
sottostante materiale prezioso hanno
valore perché l'uomo crede che ne
abbiano la fiducia e dunque il motore
che muove le cose e le rende possibile
quindi il denaro non è per forza una
realtà materiale come le banconote che
avete in mano ma un'invenzione della
nostra immaginazione collettiva in cui
tutti abbiamo riposto la nostra fiducia
tutto questo cosa dovrebbe insegnarci se
il denaro è principalmente uno strumento
nel quale la società ripone la propria
fiducia
il denaro del futuro potrà essere cose
diversa dallo strumento fatto di carta
di pietra o di tecnologia ma che meglio
rappresenterà la nostra storia come
società e i valori in cui crediamo
io non voglio dirvi che il futuro del
denaro sono i bitcoin perché nessuno ha
la sfera magica ma potete essere
d'accordo con me se dico che oggi il
sistema finanziario sta perdendo il
pilastro portante ovvero la fiducia da
parte delle persone
diventiamo consci che siamo liberi di
utilizzare lo strumento monetario che
meglio rappresenta i nostri valori e
principi
capiamo che evolvere e tanto complicato
e faticoso quanto assolutamente
essenziale perché come disse d'annunzio
o rinnovarsi o morire
grazie
[Musica]